[Music]
please welcome the very funny
Baron Vaughn me me me thank you thank
you very much hello audience if that's
your real name I am an adult which means
I am just now starting to accept the
fact that I'll never have superpowers
and that ruins all of my plans it was
get superpowers then fix my credit and I
don't know how I'm gonna do the second
without the first I clearly don't
understand that industry but I have
tried to move things with my brain at
home you know I will I'll be at home
watching TV or having a meal and the
remote of the fork is just out of reach
and I don't want to quote-unquote get up
so instead I just concentrate I'm just
like perhaps now and my brain is like
go-go-gadget are like yes brain very
funny but take this seriously and
nothing happens but if one day that fork
flew into my hand I wouldn't be
surprised that's how much I've thought
about that if it was just like schloop
as I suspected I haven't have an outfit
picked up for this mask cake time to
stop dubstep
my greatest weakness is uh
it's really old black southern women
that go to church three or more times a
week because I will do literally
anything they ask me to do especially if
they call me sugar like an all black
woman sigh excuse me sugar I'm like well
I am sweet how can I be of assistance
what that litany things to the bake sale
although black women have a trump card
that I can't deny it doesn't matter when
in the middle of the old black woman
comes up to me is like excuse me babe
can you help me with these groceries my
elevators broke you seeing I can't go up
all them stairs with all these groceries
my bones are just so brittle
you know from marching for your rights
just remember the seventh floor ain't a
spot of Selma come on babe I tried to
quit sugar
I failed I'll try again and I'll fail
because sugars in everything and it is
hard to quit it's the greatest drug of
all time because it hurts us and it's
legal I think that heroin and cocaine
wish they were sugar I think they had
posters of sugar in their walls when
they were in high school and they used
to go to sleep go on one day I'll be in
breakfast which
it's my biggest weakness breakfast
cereals home man
you knows that sugary cereals are only
like the bottom shelf of the cereal
aisle and healthy stuffs at the top so
when I at 2:00 a.m. finally find a
24-hour grocery store to indulge in my
shame I'm told a story as my gaze drops
of who I should be as opposed to who I
actually am because it's kind of like a
right there for you i level cuz you're
an adult
kocchi eat that you're not sure what's
in it you're not even sure if you said
it correctly but it's got to be great
there's pictures of wheat on the box
look at the one next to them they're
hugging and smiling know why cuz they're
gonna live past 40 Kashi eat that then
look down one more hey corn Chex is
totally fine man corn Chex is good look
twelve essential vitamins and nutrients
very important I've been told corn Chex
still doing great one more shelf I'm
losing you a little bit honey nut
cheerios okay
it's Cheerios so that's good but I'll
tell you my biggest concern there's a
cartoon on the box
but it is a cartoon B and at least bees
exist
as long as you stay with illustrations
of things that are things you're doing
okay honey notarios I'll accept it last
shelf elves aren't real why is that
tiger wearing a scarf he shouldn't be
cold he's covered in fur that captain
does not look licensed to operate a
vessel on the milk Seas and you're going
after a cereal that features a modern
Stone Age family that's not a thing you
can't have a small brontosaurus as a dog
they never existed keep it up you're
gonna end up just like this diabetic
vampire
[Music]
[Applause]